now the world's first museum of
happiness opens today in London's first
happy mmm and we're joined by Eddie
McRae who's the founder of the gratitude
garden welcome what is this all about
appreciating the being of the state of
being happy
yes well today we have this wonderful
Museum of happiness opening at the
canvas cafe in Shoreditch it's going to
have lots of things that make people
happy so a tree but you can add little
messages of gratitude on and hanging
them from the tree a post box where you
can send thank-you letters and then more
seriously some information about the
science of happiness what makes people
happy what does make people happy there
well one of the things that makes people
happy is remembering what's good about
life so quite often we can have a day
which has been a great day but we have
one argument with somebody and then at
the end of the day all that kind of goes
around in our heads is the argument even
though lots of nice things happened so
one exercise you can do is write down at
the end of the day three good things
about your day and this forces you to
kind of recognize that there were good
things that happened the gratitude
garden app that I've made actually asks
you what good things have happened
during your day and helps you do this
exercise is there a recognition then
with all the issues there may be people
watching saying well you know I don't
see the point of doing any of this but
it's human beings and perhaps as you
know citizens of the UK we are we more
negative it's a sort of natural bias I
think we are naturally likely to be
negative I mean we've evolved that way
the people who worried about running
away from Tigers were more likely to
survive from the people who enjoyed the
beautiful sunsets you know thousands and
thousands of years ago so we've evolved
to be like that but it's not necessarily
a helpful way of being in today's
society so there are actual things that
you can do to try and change that that
bias that negativity bias and make
yourself more positive
but you can't be in a constant state of
happiness can you I mean that's just not
realistic you can whether you work with
you I try every day doesn't know I mean
if the problem in society were people
being in a constant state of positivity
we'd be having a different discussion I
think but there's evidence to show that
doing a gratitude journal can make you
25 percent happier
it increases self-esteem increases
people how nice you are to others it
even increases how much exercise you do
one study showed people doing an hour
and a half more exercise who are doing a
gratitude journal so it's a really easy
way easy fun not expensive it's a way to
motivate of the gratitude you have you
look easy thank you I think Italy can't
really argue with just being nice and
positive okay
because we are we are too negative I
agree with you wholeheartedly thank you
very much I hope you enjoy the day
sounds a lot of fun be happy and we're
gonna be happy too because we're gonna
be having kids stay with us